oh what is this you guys know I had to
get a moonshot in there can you get
smacks and Vadim and this is our
unbiased blind camera comparison between
the brand new pixel 7 Pro and the iPhone
14 plus now Max went out took a bunch of
photos we haven't seen any of them
except these ones so go ahead and play
along with us and let us know in the
comments what you get so what do you
guys think about this selfie well right
away I see a huge difference I
definitely like the one on the left just
so much more sharp and all the details
everything I like the brightness too
it's so like Dynamic you can see all of
like the sun like hitting the back of
your hair and everything it's beautiful
while the other one's really flat flat
so unanimous for the iPhone the iPhone
oh whoa what do you choose for me
definitely the left one I think it's
close because I kind of see some more
detail on the right however I like the
background blur and I do like the white
balance too spot on another one for the
iPhone 14 I have to say I was really
surprised by this because this is a
macro shot on the pixel which the iPhone
can't do that but that crap turned out
really well really good here is a shot
with tough lighting wow sun's coming uh
behind that mountain there was it like
blue
um
it's like Kool-Aid
left
detail too wow I'm looking at the
waterfall and I feel like I see a lot
more detail it's a lot more Dynamic than
the other on the left side yeah yeah I
think the trees kind of give it away too
so it's an ultra wide shot here that one
is I think so what was isil doing I
don't know what the iPhone was doing but
definitely the water was not blue now
this is a portrait shot right here which
one do you guys like the one on the
right I'm seeing a lot more detail on
the right immediately a lot more detail
like you could see all the texture in
his sweater too and in his face the left
one's not bad though yeah it's still
okay but right one you guys voted for
these pixels now you guys can see it
does crop in more for years they force a
crop for portraits in this case it does
look nice even though you don't see as
much of Noah now here is another shot
it's gonna have to be the right I think
I see more detail yeah everywhere the
left one looks a little smoky all right
guys another one for the pick another
one yes now this one has a 50 megapixel
sensor for that main as you guys can see
right there it does record a 12
megapixel though whoa so this was
supposed to be a portrait well the left
one is not that is a portrait oh wait a
second like looks this is blurred yeah
but this is not and nothing happens well
the trees back there right in the world
most of this is where yeah this is good
the one on the right it's really good
that is the iPhone now there is a little
bit of an issue here uh but it did do a
better job I think overall I actually
took two FIT pictures with the pixel
because I thought maybe I messed up so
weird that was the better one yeah some
guitar man oh wow
yeah right of course wow there's a
massive difference bam you guys voted
for the pixel it has a five times
Optical lens this is a 30-time shot I
love being able to zoom in and get shots
like this yeah where the iPhone only
does a 5x you have to crop later whoa
whoa what in the world okay oh yeah this
is like this is a video I forgot oh okay
it's a video all right so we are
including four videos here uh people
said the pixel got way better with the
video this year so let's go ahead and
take a look
okay right away the one on the right
super smooth the left is like stuttery
there's noise everywhere it's flat so
that's a lot more flaring okay yeah so
this is a stabilization test
the right yeah the right for sure and
you guys voted for the iPhone pretty
good all right I think
I think this we have four total two
two okay play it so this is a slow
motion clip both have the same exact
advertised features let's look at the
Quality
lack of detail
yeah that is weird crazy it wasn't dark
at all look at that the one on the left
kills it the iPhone wins again now the
dynamic range is a little bit worse but
it doesn't have that garbage there yeah
yeah all right we have this shot right
here
very tough lighting I would have to say
left immediately that just looks
horrible and messes you up every single
way it works uh white balance better
detail better dynamic range better
everything yeah and this was completely
backlit and you guys voted for pixels
pixels that's impressive so the photos
are actually doing really well and wow
it's been a while since we had this many
differences between the phones really
now we have a portrait shot right here
wow that left wait is this it doesn't
really look like a portrait why is this
part blurry but this part is all Sharp
yeah it looks like it failed right over
here on the right and plus like the one
you want to keep in your phone you want
like the biggest difference the most
amount of blur this kills it in every
way yeah and you guys voted for the
iPhone and wow this is a case where I
would like that crop Apple doesn't give
you that crop for some reason but it
still worked better here we have a shot
of Elon wow that's a huge difference oh
my goodness like here like his eyes are
like black there's like a lack of
this looks so natural I know that looks
we say this at least once or twice every
camera Compares it looks like a DSLR
shot at least when you compare it to
that and that is the pixel now this is
not a 30 types crop it's a five times
which the iPhone does digitally but it
looks bad whoa whoa look at that I like
the one on the right it really stands
out yep
yeah look there's artifacts noise
everything plus it looks like it's kind
of out of focus ish right here this
looks bad but yeah this looks really
cool I like that looks nice and clean
all right you guys voted for the pixel
so obviously this is a macro shot I I
had to crop a lot with this one it
actually turned out better than I
thought but yes it's nice to have that
macro feature what
what in the world it's a massive
is it a sunrise or a sunset I don't know
don't tell me just look at his face
though look this is like DSLR like to
the Max and this is just like noise
artifacts he's blue but the dynamic
range I hate it dude who cares about the
dynamic range look at his face oh wow
can we mix them together it would be
nice to mix them together one on the
right this is hard dominates in this
okay Angelica you gotta make a choice
well the subject is him and he looks
better on the right so you guys voted
for the iPhone dynamic range kind of
sucks what but the subject looks great
whereas the pixel struggled I mean you
can't adjust dynamic range but it is not
as nice either and we have this shot
right here that flares is this a video
no nope
a picture taken exactly the same okay uh
they're both kind of bad yeah they're
both kind of bad honestly
this is just so flat though I'm still
gonna choose the right I'm still gonna
choose right because you got the high
dynamic range and here everything is
flat it's all one color you got no
colors man yeah that one's I'm going for
the right you guys voted for the pixel
uh now I left the shot in because the
scene was beautiful both these ones kind
of sucked at it but the one thing that
kept bugging me with the pixel is the
amount of flaring so I had to leave one
shot in because I had to keep changing
my shots the iPhone sucked at that for a
long time but this new camera bump is
terrible at all and here we have another
video let's go ahead and take a look
oh wow look at that right away I'm
seeing a ton of Shake on the right and
it's not as clean like look at the
contrast yeah wow lots of detail content
this is all flat like artifacts so much
less details it's all just like easy one
for the left you guys voted for the
iPhone once again and I do want to say I
did have stabilization turned on and
this is a 4K uh video clip and our last
video clip uh Google whoa uh you guys
could tell there's some blur but Google
added cinematic mode
um but it's a video so let's take a look
okay
oh what the heck is this
it goes from like zero to a hundred blur
this is so fake this is really natural
like on the right yeah smooth transition
oh it's pulsing it's pulsing in the
world garbage garbage can go back to the
first frame of it immediately noticing
like this whole thing and then once it
starts it just gets worse well you guys
voted for the iPhone once again that's
the last video clip we have terrible uh
and I was not trying to be mean to the
pixel
um this one on pulsing forever well the
Cinematic Mode's only 1080p not HD and
it is unusable at this point here we
have an ultra wide and tough lighting
that's cool I'm gonna have to go with
the right you got much more detail
everywhere and you actually have
different colors and some Sky yep
there's all around much more sharp yeah
pixel 7 Pro the ultra wide is nice and
we have this
look at that yeah they're right it looks
beautiful the color reproduction look
this is all flat like one kind of color
but here you have like a different range
plus much more sharp everything yeah and
that was the iPhone surprisingly uh so
the the pixel has that 50 megapixel but
it's not helping when we're zooming in
to do the shot
that's cute I let Elon take a selfie
himself
uh with his short arms so
this one's so close and it is a portion
as well I mean I like the one on the
right you see more of the background
it's kind of further away and I see more
detail too yeah this is I like the white
balance better this one doesn't even
look like a selfie yes one on the right
and you guys vote for the pixel it has a
much wider front-facing camera the
iPhone won't let you go wider if you're
taking a portrait and he has short
little arms
now we're getting to darker lighting oh
wow oh the right one the level looks
terrible the one on the right huge
difference in detail you could even
bring up the the uh brightness if you
want to but everything is noisy noise
and artifacts are everything right there
and that is the pixel with its five
times Optical now we have a portrait of
Elon here see I hate how blue this all
is though and I will say that you can
adjust that and the pixel that you
actually let you adjust that on the
phone itself but most people just take
regular shots honestly guys I'm going
with the right on this one I like it I
would rather keep that one wait is this
the first one you're disagreeing with I
like the depth roll off kind of right
there it looks more natural and just the
color balance itself is a huge
difference for me
well if I could if I could change the
style the colors I see so much more
detail on the left with a shirt with his
pants everything and you can change the
colors that's because that is the pixel
epic did I give it away earlier I think
maybe I gave it away the pixel has that
slider that you can adjust it but the
problem is you don't see the photo until
you take it and you wait like four or
five seconds for processing go into the
camera only then do you see what it
turns out like and here we have some
dark shots wow the first thing I notice
is just the side how everything is so
sharp and you can read it here and this
it just kind of gets smudged out yeah it
looks like it's blown out here so I'm
definitely going with the right I'm
seeing more detail better Dynamics look
at all this yeah dynamic range contrast
I know that one looks fantastic and it
is the pixels Ultra wide both are 12
megapixels these are software and
oh wow wow look at this like artifacty
noisy mess no that's horrible terrible
yeah yeah I mean this has to be the
pixel on the left look at that detail
this is actually oh I didn't see that
the contrast dynamic range wow the
contrast sharpness you can even read
that that's insane oh fresh basket dude
oh yes wow all right well we know what
this is this is the pixel and this is
both uh five acts of them on both of
them it's not a 30X or anything and we
have Emily wow right clear winner on the
right I mean you could actually see uh
some of the shadows and sharpness she's
not just like a blob yeah that is the
pixel once again so far at night mode
it's kicking up here really well all
right we have this regular shot oh look
at that you see all that detail we're
here everything is smudgy blown out with
this one I'ma go with the right actually
I like how the the tree and the leaves
look on both of these trees and
everything in general right I'm going
definitely for the left just like the
lights and everything which that's a
pretty like important thing in this
picture to me
and then with all like the reflection
and everything the right one is so much
worse I actually don't remember which
one is which so let's take a look
pixel and iPhone
and we have this tough lighting
situation it was very dark I think I see
more detail on the left one I see more
detail on the right actually much more
detail in the bricks oh yeah yep and the
Shadows are kind of brought up a little
bit more but uh mainly because the
bricks I'm going with the right okay I'm
just gonna go with the left I'm going
with the right you guys keep disagreeing
now yeah and we have the iPhone on the
left pixel on the right and in reality
it was actually darker than even the the
iPhone shot here we have one Elon wow
look at that so this is either probably
motion blur maybe it had the shutter
open for longer here so it um right for
sure
yeah it did have the the shutter open
three times as long that was the pixel
that needs more light there and this
whoa
whoa whoa wow
wow I don't know if we've ever had a
difference like that is so so different
but they're like equally bad I mean I'm
going with the left because to be honest
even though the right has more detail it
literally tries to make it Daylight on
everything even the sky is like so like
flat here you actually have a nice dark
sky with the Stars and I think I would
have to agree with you since I think the
sky is more important than like the tree
I know this is something I'd want like
as a wallpaper on my phone it looks like
magical you know yeah and that is the
pixel that's keeping it dark there which
is weird because the last shot uh the
one before that made it super right
oh okay so one of these is much better
than the other I mean the left one of
course the right one is like
what happened man like that potato
and Elon was trying to make a funny face
he wasn't like coughing or something in
the middle all right so for sure the
left one is the iPhone the pixel uh made
it really dark now I did not have flash
on the screen this is just the night
mode and it was extremely dark the night
mode uh where the iPhone lights up the
screen a tiny bit and it did that well
wow we're back downtown oh there's so
much more detail on the right yeah the
right just cute it's a little more flash
sharper look at the water everything is
just yeah
everything like those action box trees
are all a blur yeah right easy
but yeah that looks really detailed
oh what is this you guys know I had to
get a moonshot in there yeah dude you
would never know that that's the moon
you would never know you know what's
funny he looks like a light bulb like
last week we had a beautiful moon and I
was trying to take it even with my
iPhone uh 14 pro Max and it sucked yeah
it's I couldn't get the picture I should
have seen a Samsung would have done
better than that uh I was kind of
disappointed but I thought Google just
makes everything black around it you
know nice and clean this is just yeah
well you guys already know what that is
yeah so that side for 14 plus I tried
the best to get the best shot and that's
the best I can get oh we have this Ultra
wide here I mean it's got to be the
right hand look at that like look at all
of the noise and artifacts this just
everything's blood sugar terrible yeah
the one on the right it was extremely
dark I couldn't really see that well but
you guys voted again the pixels
wow left this is the portrait wow
yeah the one on the right almost looks
like it's once again blurry like it's a
motion blur or something and it's not
sharp left take a guess what do you
think uh the camera
I mean it's got to be the iPhone because
it has a shorter shutter speed or faster
I was gonna guess the Pixar gotta be the
last guess well
wow so it's cropping into the main
sensor it forces the side to crop in
here to get it to match wow but it could
do night mode when it's dark in a
portrait not with that not with the 14
plus wait the 14 plus can't do it no
because the pros have done it for years
yeah yes yep all right [ __ ] come on
let's keep moving oh
this is my second last shot I think you
see something yeah
will not let you take a port well
they'll let you take a portrait shot
yeah but don't let you do night mode and
that's the garbage that I got and why is
that oh cause you need lidar to do that
you need to spend another two hundred
dollars if you want to do that obviously
the pixels you don't have to do that
things to do night mode without lidar
and do a portrait it looks great it was
so dark so sorry Apple you can't use
that excuse anymore all right that was
our last oh man photo I'm excited to see
uh let me get here
okay we had 35 total votes or options
yeah
um I think I only did four uh telephoto
shots I don't know I tried not to do a
lot other than what I would do all right
guys so uh pause the video vote down
below and if you don't keep track at
least comment what really surprised you
and who wants to go first all right I'll
do it first the iPhone got 14 pixel Gods
21. I killed it and for me the iPhone
got 13 and the pace got 22.
yeah and the crazy thing is if we didn't
have those four video clips in there
yeah
it would be 10 or less yeah yeah she
literally like that almost smoked it in
video but other than that this pixel
overall did a killer killer job yeah so
if you guys have not yet seen our side
by side compare full comparison between
these two phones go check it out right
over there click that Circle above to
subscribe and we will see you in the
next video
foreign